now joining us to react to this and much
more the author of Wow
it's been 15 going on 16 weeks now
number one New York Times bestseller on
freedom of the press I call them the
great one before I get to McCabe I'm
looking at what's happening in Israel
mark and I'm thinking wow they got worse
fake news problem than we have way worse
and mark I'm thinking if this was BB
that was compromised it would be more
than a one-day story and don't ask me
any more questions you know I've been
watching what's going on in Israel it's
pretty upsetting
in a word their media sucks it's very
left-wing very anti Netanyahu much like
our media hates Donald Trump you know
the thing about Gant's it amazes me this
is a former general right you'd think
he'd know that when he uses a private
phone the Iranians are somebody or
eavesdropping and tapping in the
Iranians know what's on that phone the
Iranians know what he said that regime
knows but the Israeli people don't
because he won't come clean now in the
United States if you don't come clean
about something like that whether it's
an affair or whatever else it is you
can't get a security clearance even the
lowest official can't get why because of
the potential for blackmail it's not
enough for a politician a former general
to say they can't blackmail me nothing
happen well you should have been smart
about what you said on that phone right
general
another thing you see this today in
Politico Politico is a left-wing news
site a left-wing news site that Obama
officials love to leak to Israel accused
of planning mysterious spy devices near
the White House and the target they say
is intended to spy on Donald Trump and I
think to myself no Israel why would they
do that
then you read in the article where's
this come from three former senior US
officials in other words Obama
appointees Obama appointees planted this
they planted it in an American news site
in order to try and create hostility
between our President Trump and Prime
Minister Netanyahu or very close in fact
Trump and Netanyahu are as close as any
president and Prime Minister has ever
been and this story in my view is
planted by former Obama officials the
worst president that Israel has ever
experienced in its short life and by the
way the United States - and so I look at
this and I think to myself what's going
on here
follow this then roads it was close to
who Joel Benenson who's Joel Benenson
America and Israel he was a strategist
for Obama in 2008 and 2012 in his
campaigns and strategists for Hillary
Clinton in her 26 campaign and who's
he's a strategist for now Benny
Gant's and the blue and white party this
is a dirty trick this is a sleazy trick
because Americans and Israelis need to
know the left wing in our country and
the media in our country are like this
they work together just as they do in
Israel they're trying to take out
Netanyahu just as they're trying to take
out Trump today by the way Sean now that
you have me here see this you know what
this is
these are the ridiculous allegations
brought by a ridiculous Attorney General
in Israel against Benjamin Netanyahu now
I doubt the American people care and I
doubt the Israelis have actually read
this I read it as a former chief of
staff to a real Attorney General in the
Reagan administration this is a disgrace
an absolute disgrace like the
allegations against our president I
looked at the three allegations the
first allegation the Prime Minister of
Israel accepted cigars and champagne de
minimis gifts you know what this
Attorney General did he added gifts from
another person to make it look like the
cigars and champagne that Benjamin
Netanyahu received was an enormous
amount well you know what mr. Attorney
General
what you did is unethical what you did
is when I looked at the second charge
bribery fraud breach of trust
utterly irrational the Prime Minister
actually refused to be bribed
one media outlet seeks legislation that
would help against a media competitor in
exchange for positive news their prime
minister had no intention of promoting
the legislation and it wasn't even
possible for him to promote the
legislation because the suspension of
knesset was taking place before it can
even happen then I looked at the third
which is supposed to be the big
blockbuster charge
it's loaded with hyperbole idiotic
assertions it's about press ethics not
the conduct of the prime minister of the
of the State of Israel claims the Prime
Minister sought positive media like no
politician does that they might as well
take a crime tape and wrap it around the
Knesset because this this website you
see was going to do positive news on
behalf of the Prime Minister of Israel
and it's changed for certain policies
and regulatory changes there is no
direct evidence whatsoever in this
long-winded verbose a full of phony
adjectives charged the third charge what
the Attorney General's basically saying
is I don't like the press policy of this
particular press owner and I don't like
the policies of president of the Prime
Minister of Israel therefore I'm going
to make an allegation and these
allegations like the charges against our
president hang over the head of the
prime minister throughout the last
several several months I would just say
to the Israelis you have the modern-day
Winston Churchill don't make the same
mistake the British made because I
guarantee you with the enemies that
surround you particularly Iran you will
come to regret it that's just my
personal opinion well I happen to share
it he's been ature trillion figure moral
clarity look at what look at this
relationship with Trump oh yeah
recognize Jerusalem as the capital
oh yeah recognize the sovereignty of gol
lon look at the partnership they have I
hope and pray the people of Israel volt
look who'd think we need to keep our and
our marks show by the way every Sunday
night we have to run 10 p.m. number one
right here on the Fox News Channel